Donald Trump is changing the America
people thought they knew they're
bringing drugs they're bringing crime
they're rapists Family Values decency
decorum all challenged even threatened
by his insurgent campaign will take our
country back very soon anger and
contempt fixtures in public life this
country somehow losing its innocence
Donald J Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States
I don't know what I said I don't
remember and the fallout is being felt
well beyond politics on the streets in
the playgrounds in the churches every
time I mention her everyone screams lock
her up lock her up locker this is the
story of the trumpet
Little League baseball in Tampa Florida
where the toxic language of the campaign
is being absorbed by the children what
do you think about Donald Trump now he's
a liar and he doesn't care about our
country I think Hillary if Hillary gets
in she's gonna bring a lot of illegal
immigrants in like Syrians do you hear
people talk about him at school yes what
do they say that he's a liar races for
some in this Hispanic neighborhood
Donald Trump's anti-immigrant stance is
having a profound effect
Stephen Cruz is eight his family is
Dominican but in the US legally he's
become convinced something awful is
going to happen I don't wanna be away
from my parents
you think you're gonna be split up from
your parents yeah
is that where are you yeah if you could
talk to him what would you say I'll say
calm down and take it easy on the kids
and stop stop trying chop the young that
much do you believe that he's going to
try and split families up yes if we get
to the up to be a president I think he
will he's I don't think he's capable
award how is there hunting his capable
thinking wife says but at the same time
I see Ron him like darkness like he
doesn't care there seems to be some
anxiety and less tolerance than I've
seen in the past Val and Laura Jane
teach at a school nearby they believe
Trump has transformed their classrooms
I've heard recently things like well I'm
gonna sit over here what
the white kids and that really shocked
me that was a few weeks ago a kid had a
red hat it said make America great again
and then I saw him turn to his classmate
and show that who was a Hispanic girl
and showed her the Hat and just her face
she was so she was obviously upset by it
and she just turned around and walked
back into the classroom and he you know
high-fived with his buddies and thought
it was the greatest thing so people are
using Trump's campaign slogan to bully
in your school
oh yeah it's yeah I mean yeah they're
threatening or insulting bullying other
kids the Republican base decided to send
a drummer
a knock-down-drag-out Street Fighter
something unseen in the modern era of
politic Montgomery Alabama this city
central to the civil rights movement
understands division and fear more than
most we're here to visit the Southern
Poverty Law Center which tracks social
justice issues
Maureen Costello has gathered thousands
of stories from schools across the
country naming this new dynamic the
Trump effect for many children it's
essentially been a traumatic experience
we have children now who have been
coming to school every day
and living their lives everyday for the
last six months or so who are worried
about deportation worried about being
called Isis worried about being called a
terrorist worried about just being told
that they don't belong here and that
they are not loved and welcomed and that
they're hated and those children are
wounded by this and they are not going
to be healed just because one night a
vote happens how do you feel when you
listen to Donald Trump speak I feel
nervous and frightened I feel threatened
I feel I have spent over 40 years
teaching about American democracy I love
this country and I love the kind of
government we have built and I feel like
that is all under attack and it hurts
but some are encouraged by Trump and
deep in America's heartland powerful
forces are emerging
Matthew Heinberg is a white nationalist
we meet in a car park first he's
paranoid about people discovering where
he lives
we're allowed to film him packing
leaflets to send to supporters before
heading out to meet his target audience
we're in Beattyville Kentucky
Beattyville is an impoverished community
it's the fifth poorest town in America
and it's overwhelmingly white
working-class some people might look at
Donald Trump and think what he's done is
embolden people with racist ideas well
what he's done is he has shown that
these ideas of nationalism not globalism
are something that's popular with
everyday white Americans this is what
normal white Americans think and this is
what they've been waiting for but at the
very heart of this
is fear fear of a changing increasingly
diverse America how can you blame
America's problems on multiculturalism
isn't that terribly simplistic the
history of humankind is tribal conflict
one group against another so we as white
nationalists are advocates for our tribe
for our people and we're not content to
see ourselves become a minority in our
own countries if you do demographically
culturally economically displaced we are
here to fight for our communities and
we're not going to be pushed aside there
is interest in his ideas here driven by
isolation and hardship that people like
me want to collect it unemployment and
you think that immigration is
responsible in part for taking your work
I do I do every day Donald Trump has
brought more energy and life to the hate
movement in the United States than any
politician in modern memory he's
extremely dangerous this country has
spent the better part of its existence
trying to end racism right the original
sin of this country is white supremacy
that idea is what allowed slavery
allowed segregation allowed Jim Crow all
these terrible things to happen and it
took from the founding of the country
until the mid-60s to just change that in
the law not in the hearts minds of
people necessarily but in the law and
since Martin Luther King and the civil
rights act and so on we've spent a lot
of time trying to move away from racism
in society and Donald Trump has reversed
those efforts in basically a heartbeat
it's tragic
few places have felt the Trump effect
more keenly than in Michigan home to
America's largest Muslim community they
say the last time they felt this
marginalized was after 9/11 almost every
single one of my friends has had an
incident where someone was either trying
to run them off the road or verbally
threaten them or physically threaten
them
now it's become so common that it's
unusual
you meet someone who hasn't had
something happened to them if they are
visibly Muslim how do you feel do you
feel less safe in trumps America I do I
do I being someone that's busily Muslim
someone that says wear the headscarf I
do feel blessings I feel almost as if
there's a bull's-eye or a target on my
head if you could speak directly to
Donald Trump what would you say to him I
would tell him to soften up represent
all of the people be nice
we mark in the middle of an emotional
Civil War in this country and just like
the 19th century civil war will be
dealing with the fallout of three years
Trump is testing faith in communities
everywhere bill Doherty is a
psychologist he's been invited to speak
at his church and he believes Trump
threatens America's mental health this
is a man that a lot of women feel like
they have known in some way this is a
man that many men have experience as a
bully in their lives so there's this
psychological personal level and then
there's this sort of larger societal
level that he represents a threat to our
institutions and our democracy so it's a
double whammy Trump represents a kind of
human Molotov cocktail that is being
hurled at the establishment in the
United States
do you feel anxious about what's
happening oh yeah yeah it's it's
affected our family because there's some
Trump supporters in this family I you
know I feel anxious because I think it's
undermining our democracy in in really
profound ways it's horrifying to me that
the that people that you know I you walk
down the street that there are some
people out there that think that this is
okay it's more than just some people in
Trump millions of Americans have found a
voice he's torn apart the old order of
things exposing deep fault lines
creating nuanced shaking and shaping
what this country believes about itself
America's next president will serve for
four years the Trump effect will last
for much longer
you